[Musik]
dazu eingeladen den videos schon
gefährlich ein wahrlich nichts zu jetzt
aus diesem billigen abel super-gaus
gedacht und damit herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich komme gerade vom
einkaufen weil ab heute ist ja
tatsächlich masken pflicht und ich hatte
bis eben keine maske die ich wirklich
also muss mit maske reingehen da steht
auch wertvoll kontrolliert das und ich
glaube wenn du keine auffassung ist zu
geld wird 250 euro das so wir machen
heute tech talk live hacks part war
keine ahnung 7 oder so ist das ja
bestimmt schon und der erste live act
sollte das mit der maske sein den ich
euch mal kurz die rheinländer wie man
wenn man jetzt keine maske hat einfach
eine unterhose nehmen kann und die sich
praktisch ja also das hat schon super
geklappt ich war gerade mit dieser und
hause wo kopf einkaufen
ich habe so viele so genial angeguckt
jemand ganz kurzer aus mit
ganz einfach und schnell einfach und
schnell und das lustige war ich bin so
um 13 uhr einkaufen gegangen oder
bisschen später dann komme ich wieder
steht eine vorher von marie hier vor der
tür die uns diese masken gegeben hat die
sind selbstgemacht balla ich wollte
meinen link in die beschreibung ist ja
nur nette werbung hier oder drei stück
auf eine für dich und jetzt haben wir
masken gut das langweilig sind noch
immer zuerst leute wir machen heute
wieder geniale live-act also ich habe
einige rausgesucht und ich würde sagen
wir starten mit dem ersten denn wenn ich
euch hier ein
ich musste mich selber noch mal kurz
anschauen letzten titel bei
warum also wenn das mädel das kann dann
kann ich das so auch oder ablösten ich
habe hier zwei mineralwasser besorgt
also das sagen ziemlich locker aus auf
dem video
ich bin mal gespannt ob ich das jetzt
auch hinkam also man kann ja so kann ich
das auf jeden fall aber so sind
natürlich noch das auch so
glock wir gehen auf jeden fall besser
aus da hast du recht leute wären wir
jetzt wiederum verschenkt auf jeden fall
meint hintergrund meint witsch sehr
wichtig also ganz gut gründen nicht
richtig dagegen meine hand ich bin ja
rechtshänder ist der deckel weg springt
ja eigentlich maxime wandel ist der
deckel zu oder ich glaube da ist
hereingeflogen lassen auf seiner mission
ist eine decke geflogen
erstmals sei gemacht hier aber gut dass
wir draußen gemacht also das mittel
konnte das auf jeden fall besser als wir
am anfang habe ich eben meine hand weh
getan
die hat sich so umgeknickt möchte egal
also das funktioniert auf jeden fall
schon einmal musste noch ein bisschen
perfektionieren wenn ihr damit wirklich
vor euren freunden angeben wollte ich
übe das noch okay lass mal mein zimmer
gehen
ich habe mich auch freuen kommen wir zum
nächsten der ist krass ich weiß nicht
ich bin mal gespannt was du dass du
sanktionen noch durch mehr lenken und
zwar geht es darum geheime und neue
filme und serien zu können ja ich hab
ich hab das jetzt mal ein bisschen
vorbereitung hat mir die abgeholt aus
dem video
die ist allerdings in deutschland
irgendwie ein bisschen anders ich denke
aber es sollte trotzdem funktionieren
also ich mache das auch nicht zum ersten
mal muss ich sagen aber es gibt
wahrscheinlich sehr viele leute die das
nicht wissen und für die test wir das
jetzt machen
er ist hier einfach mal auf die app und
ihr könnt sehen dass sie kein bisschen
anders aus als im video ich weiß nicht
woran das liegt wahrscheinlich weil die
deutschen bisschen anders ist und
trotzdem kann man jetzt aber ganz viele
verschiedene länder ausgeben wie zum
beispiel kalifornien gut das ist kein
land aber die usa kalifornien oder texas
united kingdom australia or japan kanada
singapur deutschland indien
ich glaube das ist auch alles so was du
brauchst theoretisch kann ja auch mal
schauen was es so in japan gibt oder in
indien ganz viele bollywood finden und
so bestimmt da habe ich dir an meiner
seite rausgesucht auf der irgendwelche
serien aufgeführt sind dies in
deutschland nicht gibt oder nicht mehr
gibt wie auch immer zum beispiel
twilight so jetzt schauen wir mal ob es
das wirklich nicht wird twilight sohn
kann ich ohne vpn in deutschland auf
jeden fall nicht finden wir schließen
das flex und aktivieren jetzt mal hier
den vpn texas usa
jetzt denkt mein handy ich bin in texas
und jetzt schauen wir einfach noch mal
rein und ich denke beziehungsweise hoffe
dass man das jetzt wieder schauen kann
und wir haben direkt am anfang der
twilight so keine ahnung was das ist
habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt aber
du kannst es auf jeden fall schauen wenn
du in amerika bist in deutschland geht
das nicht und ich bin mir sicher das ist
mit jeder menge serie den film so also
versucht das kemal und schaut was ihr da
so finden könnt wenn ihr schon ganz nett
fix durchschaut räumen der jetzigen zeit
ist das ja genial oder den einzigen
nachteiligen wir haben könnten ich
glaube das meiste ist dann nicht auf
deutsch
aber jetzt wird vorher in die skills to
learn noch englisch because if you don't
you in englisch so gut sind you can do
better ins google zu lernen machen wir
so weiter herzlich willkommen in unserer
luxus küche hier wollte das ist die
nächste küche wir schauen uns den
nächsten live an kann der ist nice und
ich bin wirklich gespannt ist
let's go
der kindsmörder das laster business
mashups also ich muss sagen ich bin so
seit einem halben jahr als ich auch gern
mal was am anfang dachte ich er dieses
grüne zeug will ich gar nicht probieren
ist aber schon ganz lecker deswegen bin
ich jetzt mal gespannt ob das wirklich
so gut schmecken kann wie diese frau im
video erzählt vietnamesische den die
kasse das finden wir jetzt natürlich
heraus ich habe eingekauft einmal
wirklich wundervolle keuschheit dann
eine avocado und talente kondensmilch
von meiner lieblingsmarke nein zur
welcome to x cooking channel schau dir
doch einfach mal diese geniale avocado
an also wenn das keine avocado aus dem
bilderbuch ist dann weiß ich auch nicht
die dommitzscher aus oder so dann kommt
ein beziehungsstreit ist alles so in den
teller hat gehört dass alles unfälle
ich mache jetzt einfach mal keine ahnung
wir machen mal ein bisschen ja ich will
nicht zu viel so ein bisschen geht man
jetzt kommt dieser kondensmilch darüber
sänger jeremy content nicht verwendet
okay also im video star das irgendwie
keiner aus wir machen einfach mal ein
bisschen so jetzt wird es hier ein
bisschen gerührt sondern auch zu
eingeladen den videos schon ungefähr
ähnlich einladend aus ich habe
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel
kondensmilch verwendet aber das schadet
jetzt auch nicht es ist auf jeden fall
sehr kann meine hand unten drunter
also ich würde sagen ich probiere das
jetzt einfach mal ob das also es ist
schon ein neuer geschmack den man von
einer avocado wahrnimmt allerdings mein
persönlicher geschmack ich weiß nicht
also das schwierig werden avocados
lieber aufs brötchen
trotzdem wäre es mag also ist jetzt auch
nicht schlechter bewertung 1 bis 10 von
dir sechs anhalt mehr ist nicht drin
also gut
das ist doch nicht schlecht
und so ermer kritisch unterwegs ich habe
nochmal meine kondensmilch mit der von
der verglichen irgendwie weil die von
der ein bisschen dickflüssiger das
endresultat vergleich aus als ich hoffe
ich habe das gut nach immer vielleicht
springt ja irgendwie mit einer anderen
milch oder so ich kann ja auch so ein
einnahmen aber auch weil ich zeig euch
immer die red
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht
also ich glaube auch nicht daran wie
sollen das gegen diese diese dosis total
zu warte mal kurz ich habe hier jetzt
mal eine cola besorgt und lipton ice tea
also wir können das mit zwei
verschiedenen produkten machen
das einzige was jetzt gemacht hat der
hat das jetzt hier umgedreht oder hier
oben drauf und das jetzt aufgemacht und
dann soll das abgehen
ich versuche machen
jetzt habe ich ein problem jetzt muss
das sei irgendwie ausstechen
das heißt jemand auch noch probiert hat
kann man nicht bis zum punkt kurs um
knacks ja okay ich vergesse das geht
nicht
oder hat er nicht allein
leute das ist ich glaubte als vorher
aufgeschnitten bei dem das auch so
leicht aus hier noch mal ein ganz kurze
einspieler
ich glaube der tvr ein gekettet oder so
also da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass es funktioniert die habe ich jetzt
zum glück noch auf bekommen
immer diese völker leute ich würde sagen
danke fürs zuschauen wenn ihr sagt
machen noch mehr parks lasten nach oben
da ich habe auf jeden fall auch super
viel in petto was irgendwann zeigen kann
macht unglaublich viel spaß abonnieren
mich auch trick top-30 alex läufst alex
eigentlich sollte alex wie mittlerweile
heißen aber irgendwie hat das immer noch
nicht geklappt aber nicht den kanal
abonniert auch super gerne mal einen
neuen kanal alex lauda gibt's nämlich
nice connection auftritt scream ich
meistens abends ab 21 oder 22 uhr könnt
ihr auch gerne folgen und das war es
genug werbung gemacht danke fürs
zuschauen daumen nach oben kanal
abonnieren
haut rein
[Musik]